Part of the second law of thermodynamics
says that
entropy in the universe is only increasing.
I put an exclamation mark here,
because it sounds like a very profound statement.
At all levels, it is.
And in order to get a proper attitude to the lesson,
I show this picture of the night sky
from the Hubble Space Telescope.
Each of these points
is not a star.
Every point is a galaxy.
This is a galaxy.
This is a galaxy here.
I hope this picture will
they put you in a more "cosmic" mood.
Let us think what the initial statement says.
Entropy in the universe only increases.
We can define entropy as disorder
in one system.
We're talking about the number
conditions a system can accept.
Then we say in the universe.
We can also say that entropy
a closed system can only increase.
A system that is completely closed,
is a system that does not interact with its surroundings,
and the universe is a closed system.
There is nothing beyond her that can interact
thermodynamic.
I will make a quick revision of open and closed systems,
to make sure you understand them.
If I had a campfire,
I have a few splitters, and here
I have a fire.
It's a campfire.
If we only concentrate on wood and fire,
this will be an open system.
Because it obviously has thermodynamic interactions
with the middle.
The system radiates heat.
Warm the molecules of air around you.
It radiates light into the universe.
There may be interaction between the rest of the
universe and system.
So it is not isolated from everything else.
But the closed system is isolated.
It is very difficult to get
created a truly closed system in everyday life.
But we can get closer to one.
Closed system you may know
from the near past, is the cold bag.
In a cold bag we try,
thermodynamically isolate
the inside of the bag
from the outside environment, from the rest of the universe.
That's how it works, we have some kind of thing
insulating material.
For example, styrofoam.
We can use the refrigerator bag,
to store ice.
But it is not a perfect closed system,
because in the end, the heat from
the rest of the universe will warm the walls of the refrigerator bag.
Then this heat will surrender
and will warm up
ice.
It will melt it.
This is not a prefab closed system,
but it comes close to one,
because at least we try
to isolate it from thermodynamic interactions
with the rest of the universe.
I can make her cover,
to show that we really try to isolate it.
In scientific laboratories
you can see much better models
of closed systems.
But even at a certain level,
interact with the rest of the universe.
Really closed system
is the universe.
Outside it there is nothing that can have thermodynamic interactions.
Let's think about this definition.
Entropy in the universe can only increase.
Why does this sound logical?
The best example I can think of,
is a simple diffusion.
Let's say I have a court.
I have a court,
I will do it
closed vessel.
Let's say this is some kind of thing
a theoretical ideal closed system.
Let's say I have the ideal gas.
I have molecules of ideal gas here.
They have an average temperature,
but this means that each molecule has its own
own kinetic energy.
Everyone moves in different directions.
What will happen over time?
Those on the left
will bounce off this wall.
And they will go
in this way.
Over time, we will come to a situation where,
in which the system will look like this.
The system will
it looks like that. These six particles -
These six particles will spread
in court.
They will spread to the vessel through diffusion.
They will occupy much of the space in the court.
What happened during this process?
When particles were limited
in this small part of the court,
there were fewer possible system states.
We had a lower entropy than here,
when the particles filled the vessel.
Now there are more possible locations
and more possible system orientations.
We have more different states.
We have higher entrances,
higher, higher,
higher entropy.
In general, the processes in which entropy
are rising, are called irreversible processes,
irreversible, irreversible processes.
Why are they irreversible?
There is some possibility
molecules to reunite
in this corner of the vessel.
But it is very small.
And this is an example only
with six molecules.
In a real system we will have
much more than six molecules.
We will have millions, millions,
millions, millions of molecules.
We're talking about 20 to 30 zeros.
That's why
it is very unlikely that they will all cum together
and to create a smaller volume,
when they have already executed the court.
That's why we do not see smoke turning naturally
in some shaped particle
or take up less space,
instead of throwing out the court.
This is irreversible,
because we started with a smaller number
possible states
and a smaller volume,
but we have received a greater number of possible states.
The universe is constantly doing this.
That's why entropy in the universe can only grow.
There are some processes,
where it seems that entropy does not increase so much.
If we have a billiard ball here,
and we roll it down,
she will hit another billiard ball here,
will impart the impulse to the other ball.
It seems like this can happen in the other direction.
As if the other billiard ball could hit this one
and bring it back.
At macro level
this seems like a reversible process.
People can call it reversible.
It seems as if entropy does not increase so much.
But if we go down to a micro level -
I'll make it clear.
First, this ball moves,
and this is immobile,
then we are in a state where this moves,
and this is still.
It does not seem that entropy has increased so much.
Sometimes this process is called reversible because
we can see
cases in which this ball is back.
Pink can hit the yellow
and the bail can go back,
as if we were returning the film strip.
But even if that happens if we look at the micro level,
we will see that heat has been created.
Some molecules of the billiard ball pass at a higher energy level
from collisions with each other and friction with the air,
as the ball rolls over the ground.
These molecules never
will not return to their previous state.
So, actually, entropy
in the system is increasing.
Even in our everyday life
and in thermodynamics,
people to talk about reversible processes,
they are only approximately reversible.
Even when entropy increased only a little,
this increase is greater than zero.
Here we have irreversible reactions.
Diffusion is an obvious example.
It is clear that we have an increase
of entropy and probability
this system returns to its original state
is very small.
In reality, this can not be observed,
because we are talking about molecules whose number is a number
with 20 to 30 zeros.
The probability of returning to their initial state is very small,
you will have to wait a very long time
and you will never see something like this happen again.
I hope it is clear.
The disorder,
the number of states that a system may have,
increases with increasing number of interactions.
That's why warmth is very important.
Everything You Do -
While I'm doing this video,
my body produces heat.
The heat dissipates in the universe.
This adds more possible states,
which the universe can accept.
When I move my hand,
the digital pencil I use creates friction.
It also releases heat in the universe.
My computer is working, it also releases heat
in the universe.
Watching this video, you also release heat in the universe,
The electronics that run in your computer's cables,
emit heat in the universe.
All this increases the number of states the system can take,
when we think of a molecular level.